Muslims get by real estate you know you
can buy real estate but he's saying you
can't take a loan on it because you pay
interest with loans but that's like some
of the basics of real estate that's
exactly
my charity I'm here on the ground as you
can see behind me this is a home that
has been destroyed by the earthquake
alhamdulillah what I have in my hand is
our food pack that we're giving to these
victims that I have been suffering from
the earthquake my brothers and sisters
we need your support you know these
brothers and sisters what they've done
is they've come together as a community
and made a communal kitchen where they
can cook this stuff this is why we're
giving out milk uh tomato puree tea
sugar oil flour so they can make
themselves food other than sisters carry
on supporting one and one you operate on
100 donation policy this is a video to
sneak out on my run and I'm calling them
to a live discussion because I think
there's so many misconceptions that's
happening you know pretend many matches
they've done reaction video to my video
so there's a misunderstanding and
recently sneakers on a video about oh my
gosh interest is Haram as well Muslims
get by real estate you know you can buy
real estate but he's saying you can't
take a loan on it because you pay
interest with loans but that's like some
of the basics of real estate that's
exactly I want to say something to those
people in the comment section please
understand something yes but Ali radela
and said do not tell the people what
they're not ready to hear do you want
them to disbelieve in Allah's messenger
all of us have a different faith when he
is new stop saying this is
if Islam was to come with prohibitions
nobody would have come to Islam Allah
knows the creation that's why he gave
certain Commandments slowly and slowly
and slowly so people's imans can grow
subhanallah that's what Allah in the
Quran they say we believe don't say you
believe that say you have submitted
Allah the finishes between the Muslim
every movement is a Muslim but not every
Muslim is a movement a movement is a
Believer who believes certainty so to
you for you guys to go and pick on
sneako you're putting him off he needs
to understand the concept when I first
came to Islam there were certain things
I was like what really when I heard that
the sahabas fought each other I was like
no way the best of evil but this
happened is in reality it teaches a
lesson but we need to be very very
careful so therefore I'm inviting my
brother sneako and my brother Myron
please I would love to have a live
discussion with you guys and we can talk
about all of these matters to Islam
whatever I know anything that I don't
know I would try my best to point you
guys the right direction but it'll be
nice to sit down and talk about when it
comes to different matters of you know
um women money uh status all that kind
of stuff we can talk about all of that
so to my brother sneaker just understand
that an example that I'm going to give
you if you do the life of idlis shaytan
and Adam this will give you a direct
answer to the issue of Interest yes
trust me you will totally understand and
a lot of things in Islam will make sense
to you this is the advice that I want to
give you in person alive or we can do it
without it doesn't need to be on camera
I genuinely it's not about the camera I
promise you if you guys want a free wave
conversation off camera on Zoom or
whatever off camera I am more than happy
to do this it doesn't need to be on
camera believe me I don't give a damn
about that that's not important for me
so brother sneaker if you're watching
this understand take its step and slowly
ignore the Muslims that are from Islam
gradual process it took me 10 years to
come where I am and I've got a long
journey to go so take it easy don't let
people overwhelm you and it's going to
take it's going to be overburdened for
you and your going to end up crumbling
don't take it easy at a time don't take
everything that people in the comments
say there are a lot of enemies of Islam
that are saying things just to put you
up so in a nutshell I would say my
brother sneako that understand
everything Allah has legislated there is
a reason behind it there's the wisdoms
behind it and there's a reason behind it
as well so just bear that in mind and
believe me there are so much more Baraka
once we understand have a relationship
with Allah the reason you're saying this
stuff is because you're still a Muslim
once you reach the stage of being a
mockman a True Believer like a true way
you're like this makes sense to me I
have trust in God if God says look I
live in a one bedroom flat I pay 1200
pounds a month this is really expensive
with my three daughters I am somebody
that if I want I can make like arguments
like if I wanted quarter of a million
pounds a year yeah okay I can make it
but the point is I'm not concerned about
money my aim is not motivation money
money let me imagine I don't care about
this life yes this doesn't mean I make
my family self-handle we are good we are
more than happy we are more happy and
content with this rent than me going and
buying a house on interest which is a
waging is as good as Waging War against
Alliance messenger it's a major sin so
to me I am more than happy to be in a
one-bedroom flat for the rest of my life
even if it means I sleep on the sofa and
my family sleep on the bed while I sleep
on the floor as long as we are pleasing
Allah and he is happy with me I don't
give a damn what anybody says oh you I
don't care the reason why I don't
however if I had some money saved if I
was making some money and I had the
means to buy a house or there's
different means of Halal ways of buying
a property of course I would do that I'm
not going to say no to that because it's
Halal doing transaction doing business
is permissible it's interest that is not
permissible because it takes an
advantage of the week and makes them
makes the poor poor and the rich ritual
it's the whole system that destroys you
as a whole and this is the reason why
the economic system that we're in
collapses here and there every now and
then so the Islamic principle the way
it's done business is permissible you
can do business you're a businessman
carry on doing business but interest is
not permissible my dear brother however
we will speak of that inshallah and
please understand the blessings of God
in a one bedroom flat it is more beloved
and there'll be so much more blessing
than being in a mansion at the
displeasure of God and there will be no
blessing in that house now I'm not
saying if you've already bought a house
that's fine because you didn't know
we're just talking about taking gradual
steps and knowing and understanding
that's what I want to say inshallah and
know that happiness contentment peace in
the heart blessings come from God not
how big your Mansion or house is and the
risk means what the queen has a massive
Palace hundreds of bedrooms she only
gets to sleep in one mini toilets she
gets to only defecate in one yes she had
so many foods to eat she can only eat
certain amount which means what that is
what has been written and dedicated to
her by God Almighty so the point is what
let the blessings and the happiness and
the contentment come from God even if
you are sleeping on a sofa you'll be
happy my brother understand that and I'm
looking forward to hearing from you to
have a nice discussion with you guys
inshallah take care till next time
as well I got love for you guys please
understand there's not everything of
course I don't agree with the stuff you
guys say you want either with myself but
just know it's nothing but love I'm not
here for the views and the money and
this that believe me that's not the case
and until next time my dear brothers
assalamualaikum may Allah keep you guys
firm and strong inshallah take care